- Cheers.
You're gonna be impressed.
- Oh my--
- hold on, hold on.
All right, I cheated, I cheated.
God dammit.
(heavy bass music)
- [Woman] Good morning, how are you, sir?
- [Gary} Good, Thank You.
- [Man] Oh man, I started
probably when I was 15,
Call of Duty, I transitioned
into playing professionally. And then--
- Lets sit down here.
Gather as much attention
as you can right now,
'cause it will work out.
The biggest mistake you
could make right now
is get so caught up in the finances,
even at this lucrative level,
where you're giving up exposure.
I think of it as similar to like Mad Dog
on Mike and the Mad Dog.
He was one of the biggest
sports radio guys.
He went to Sirius.
Howard Stern.
Howard Stern's decline in culture
was when he cashed out and went to Sirius,
'cause less people could hear him.
My big belief right now
is when you have something
like YouTube and what
Facebook's about to do,
where you're getting all the exposure
and you're making some of the money,
that's fuckin' brilliant,
because you're not in a rush,
you're making real money.
It's not like, you know,
everyone's blessed here.
I think if you go and do something,
even it's with Netflix,
though Netflix is probably at scale now,
but like, the only thing I would say
is get as much exposure as possible,
create as little friction
for your audience as possible.
I think nobody in this space
has really made a go-to podcast yet,
like a top, I have a top 100 podcast,
that shouldn't be, I shouldn't.
There are far bigger people,
I will never be that famous,
maybe, but, here's what I could say.
If you really made a
commitment to a podcast,
much like when you're younger
you're gonna have bigger
audiences on YouTube,
and back in the day Vine, or Snap,
no question podcasts
are skewing older enough
where all the 13, 14, 15 year olds
are not in play for now.
In 36 months they will be,
so to me at this young of an age,
in this blessed of a situation you've got,
it's not like you, you
know back in the day
it was like pay your dues, pay your dues,
pay your dues, then you can cash out.
You're cashin' out now.
This is real economics, right.
- It's at scale pretty much at that point.
- But think about what you wanna scale.
To be what you wanna scale is awareness.
You want every fuckin'
person here to stop you,
basically, our end goal, everyone's.
This dude comin' right
now, he's really oh, shit,
or look at you and know who you are.
This guy, the number
one goal for all of us
is that this guy knows who we are.
- No, I agree, I agree.
I mean I think it's a big
deal, it's a big, big deal.
- Big deal.
- Awareness and just any kind of a--
- So to me it's like hundred
million fuckin' whatever,
good two hundred million,
start another channel.
Go do more collabs, this,
I'm gonna tag the fuck out of you,
a whole universe of people who right now,
as you know, 25 to 75
year old business people
who are like okay, Gary
V's gonna go harder
at Twitch, eSports, so for that world
I'm gonna come at it a different way
than than your audience comes.
They're gonna all inevitably follow you.
Like you and Broman and Ninja like
the first five or six people
I do something with are
gonna have business,
you're inevitably gonna get reached out to
just because of this clip
by a Fortune 500 company
to do something 'cause this was the seed
of where they became aware of him,
so this is exactly right.
And you could do that with hip-hop and
skateboarding and moms
and just, and that's it.
- And then I'll get atta-boys.
- You've got a tricky
job because the manager,
you know, obviously you wanna justify
why he's going with you,
bring business opportunities,
but you need to find
the right communication
with your partners, it's a trade off,
you can't have both.
Like in today's world,
the more you can not monetize, the better.
Every time you ask for
somebody to buy a hoodie,
or when I ask for a sneaker, right,
my sneaker right hook on Instagram
was my lowest performing piece of content.
No matter how much value you bring,
when you ask for something else,
that's why I like things like
AdSense and other things.
People shit on them because there's
pennies on the dollars, meanwhile,
- I mean as long as you grow those pennies
they become real dollars.
- Well yeah, at your scale, but correct,
comma, you're losing nothing.
Whereas when you're like hey
everybody, buy my hoodie,
you're losin' somethin'.
Hey everybody I love this
coffee, you're losin' somethin'.
Hey everybody, like,
buy my cryptocurrency,
you're gonna lose somethin'.
So you know, my biggest advice,
this young, this early, fucking
get as much exposure as,
like make a video that's called
Explaining Twitch to Moms,
and then take your AdSense money and run
$50,000 worth of Facebook ads
against 40 to 60 year old women,
now you got somethin'.
You see where I'm goin'?
It's different thinking.
- You make a really good point,
I mean a lot of times
lots of kids notice me
when I'm in like, more kid friendly areas
and their parents come up
to me and they're just like
what do you do?
Why does my kid wanna take a photo,
and they have no idea what their kids
are engaged in right now.
- And they're gonna care,
and they demonize
technology and video games.
- Exactly, because there
are certain creators
if your kid is underage
they shouldn't be watching.
- For sure, that's every parent,
some parents care, some don't.
To your point, that will
be a parenting thing,
but if you make a video
and say hey mom, hey dad,
before you jump to conclusions
and think your kid's wasting your time,
I make seven figures a year,
I did this, I had happiness, I was home,
look, that's you reaching
out to that audience,
kind of in the reverse of what I've done.
I have always historically
skewed more 35 to 75
and I, in the last 18
months, have skewed younger,
because of how I focused on
YouTube, or Instagram, right?
Now with Twitch I'm gonna have
a whole new world of
people because I'm gonna,
you know, the same reason all these,
you know the night the
Ninja thing's going down
he's like DMing me a lot of people
that are building personal brands,
many on Twitch.
Already you're either kind of watching me
or really watching me and
a lot of them haven't,
but I'm gonna bring them value,
'cause I'm only lookin'
to come into the community
for two core reasons.
One, how do I help the leaders
in it achieve what they want,
whether that's financial or
exposure or fame, whatever.
And two, just create culture moments
where I'm playing old
school games against,
just fun shit, right?
Like just talk a little shit,
I'm excited because like,
you know people are really
funny about new platforms,
they're always like oh,
you're getting on now?
And I'm like dude, I was playing
Paperboy before your mom--
- Oh, I love Paperboy, Paperboy is legit.
- Before your mom was even
thinking about your dad,
you know?
So it's really fun,
I'm excited about that,
but all right, see ya, man.
It's super meta, right?
We were just talkin' about video games
and eSports and actual sports.
I'm here at the NFL Draft,
what's my first meeting?
With you, so I think that's exactly right.
I think that's exactly
right. We should go inside?
- [Man] We have a better spot over here.
- Coming.
- Yeah, so have an awesome
day, take it easy, kill it.
- I will.
- Yeah, thank you so much.
- Yeah, man, lookin' forward to--
- Yeah, let us know how we can help.
- We'll get connected.
- Thanks man, have a good one.
- Thank you man, take
care, talk to you soon.
Actually you know what?
I'm tryin' to make some more contacts.
Babin, you'd be proud of me,
I'm makin' more contacts.
- Take care.
- We found a good spot over there.
- Let's go, let's go.
I should check my email real quick.
Structuring day just had
a meeting with Preston,
talkin' to eSports, I'm in Dallas,
woke up at 4 a.m. this
morning, got on a flight,
got out here to Dallas, NFL Draft,
huge day for Vaynersports
in the green room
for the first time.
Big accomplishment this
early in the situation,
obviously very excited
for Josh Jackson's family,
big day for him, we'll see where he lands.
The Jets are picking third,
the quarterback of the
future is coming home,
so we'll see what that's about.
I've got another little interview here,
then gonna do some Vaynersports stuff,
we'll see how much we can film and not,
I'm not quite sure,
but it's a big fun day,
a little breaking of the normal patterns
of vlog, but I'm excited about it,
really excited about it.
- And what's cool about this is like,
I've seen this happen to where
you put out so much goodwill and content
in the marketplace to where you
don't even need to sell, like it's done,
by the time people see you
they already know they wanna buy
versus people trying, do
the opposite of no value
and you sell, sell, sell.
- That's because I'm a marketer
and a branding guy, not a salesman.
But I'm also a salesman,
look at the earlier question I asked you.
You said what are you gonna do?
I said sell, I know how to
sell, I know how to brand.
The best way to sell in the world
is not to run retargeting programs
or affiliate marketing,
it's build a fuckin' brand.
You think my man here is wearin'
those Nikes because
they cookied him, right?
Like, everybody here,
everything they're wearing,
the underwear I'm fuckin' wearing,
what is it, Calvin Klein.
It's fuckin' brand, it's fuckin' brand,
it's all brand, that's exactly right.
I don't wanna ask people to buy my shit.
I wanna say I have a new sneaker out
and people buy that shit.
I have a new book out, of course.
And here's the best part,
and this is the most important
fuckin' part in the entire game.
When I ask for something,
come see me speak,
come buy my sneaker, come buy my book,
I give away all this free shit
better than anyone, I think
I'm at the top of the game.
Free, free, if they don't, I understand.
I have zero expectations to convert,
too many people are giving away shit?
When you give with expectation
you're a piece of shit,
you're not a good person.
When you give, and you have expectation
you're a manipulator, you're not a giver.
I give and have zero expectations.
The chips will fall where they are.
If it goes great, Mazel Tov,
if not, I wasn't providing
enough value, that's on me.
I don't give, I'm not doin' this interview
for any other reason than I know
that it's leverage for you
and it's gonna put you
on and you can use it
for other shit that you wanna do.
And you know how good that makes me feel?
That's real life.
- And I think that the
cool thing about that
is from a systems point of view.
That does not create
resentment within you,
'cause if you were engaging
- Correct!
- You eliminate the sort of negativity.
- I have zero expectations of everybody.
I could give a fuck.
I have zero expectations
of my own employees.
Many will argue with me
in my own organization
that one of my shortcomings
is my lack of expectatiion.
I'm just overly, to a fault,
I would argue to a fault, empathetic.
And I've brought it back to create
more accountability and candor,
but you're very smart to
follow up what I said by that.
That was a very good job by you,
that was the right insight.
You know why I'm always fuckin' happy?
I don't fuckin' expect
anything from people.
Most of you are unhappy
'cause you've got
expectations of somebody.
Your mother, your friend,
what you did at work,
your boss, your homie.
When I lend someone $20,
I may pretend that shit's gone.
I'm givin' you $20.
- This morning I had one funny question
here I was debating whether to ask.
- Fuckin' ask it.
- I'm gonna ask it, with my two cents,
but the question is,
what was your payout from
your dad's wine business
to build this business?
And my answer in my mind is like dude,
it's the work ethic, it's the
grind, it's the integrity.
- Financially it was zero,
financially it was zero.
When I left, you know
VeynerMedia was started
by me selling a client from Gillette
an $80,000 program and that
was the money that was started.
The payout was dick, I have
zero percent of the business,
I didn't get a loan, nothing.
I built that business for my family
'cause my family brought me to America
and raised me perfect, and so nothing.
The payout was zero, zero dollars.
Zero, that's why when
people talk shit I laugh.
I competed against people
that raised a million
dollars, like come on,
you weren't given a liquor store.
I sure wasn't, come and fuckin' look
at my fuckin' taxes.
Come see me motherfucker,
I built my fuckin' parents'
liquor store for them.
Facts.
Now come see me, when you got an excuse,
oh easy for you, Gary V,
you've got a three million
dollar liquor store.
Dickface, go read the fuckin' articles.
I started in a company that was
doing three million dollars,
making three hundred thousand in profit,
I worked my dick off from 22 to 34,
15 hours a day to build a business
for my parents that I
left at 34 with nothing.
Now tell me who had it worse, dick.
- There you go.
- Yeah, there I go.
And then, that's my thing right?
For years, I never clarified that.
The reason I'm not mad
at people for saying it
is I didn't talk about it,
because you know it was a family business,
I didn't know,
I didn't wanna put my
family's business out there,
but now I talk about it with fire
because I'm just tired of your excuses.
And fuck me, who gives a
fuck what I accomplish?
Don't look at me,
look at somebody who's fuckin' born
in the deep jungles of whatever
and comes to America fuckin',
my parents did it better than me,
fuck me, my parents
came here with nothing,
lived in a studio at 23 years old
with a hundred dollars.
Fuckin' forget me,
there's 50 million people
that came from dick shit
and fuckin' made it,
so what the fuck's your excuse?
Entitlement, you're fuckin' entitled.
If you ever bought a $5 Starbucks coffee
you're fuckin' soft.
If you ever, in your life,
bought a $5 fuckin' coffee from Starbucks,
you are fuckin' soft.
Globally, in the 7.7 billion people,
you're fuckin' fancy, you're soft.
A $5 fuckin' cup of coffee?
Fuck you, so I don't wanna hear it
from the people in my comments
or people behind my back.
You live in fuckin', you live in,
like 99% of my comments are from people
from first world countries, like fuck you.
What? Your best friend's parents
bought him a BMW and not you,
you fuckin' soft piece of shit.
I can't deal with it.
It's fuckin' ridiculous.
People are oh, you're mad at your homie
'cause their parents,
his parents, her parents
paid for their Coachella trip
but you hadda work to pay for yours?
You went to Coachella!
What is the matter with you?
What's your name?
- Meesha.
- Meesha, how are you?
- Oh my god.
- How you doin'?
- I just moved from New York
and I'm just fuckin' walkin',
like 'bout to give my resume
to coffee shops and shit like that.
I listen to you every fuckin'
day, like you're sick.
- Thank you.
- Oh my god.
- Thank you, give me one more hug.
- I feel like it was meant to be.
- It is meant to be.
- Like oh my god this is the universe,
like, I'm like really
startin' from the bottom.
- Good.
- I listen to your shit,
like your shit is, okay,
I just caught chills, I'm
like is that a fucking camera?
You can't be fucking kidding me,
like right here?
Like, oh my god.
- You wanna take a photo?
- Yes please, I just was
all in my Snap, okay.
- [Man] You want a selfie or--
- Please?
- [Man] I got you.
- Okay, let me get my shit together.
- Your shit looks amazing.
- Okay, thank you.
- [Man] All right, right
here we go three, two, one.
- I don't have my phone with me.
- Well, let's, no,
we're gonna take a photo
and we're gonna email it to you.
- For real?
- For real.
Text it to him right now,
let's make sure we don't fuck it up.
- No, my thing was just,
- What's your name?
- Cameron, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, my
guy. What's your number?
- To show love,
and show respect.
- Thank you, my guy.
- I see what you do,
I hear about it a lot,
I listen to it a lot, I take it in,
and I don't have any crazy questions
or anything like that,
I really feel confident
and I know that god's got me
where I'm supposed to be
at, and I'm in my process,
just like you're in your process.
- 100% man, you're in the beginning, man.
- Just wanted to show love.
- Thank you man, thank you for doin' that.
- Be blessed.
- Thank you, you to, my man.
- I know you're busy, is it
cool if I take a picture?
- How are you?
- Matt.
- Matt, nice to meet you.
- So let's do a selfie.
Are you shootin' some
videos for your social?
- I was just doin' an interview,
I'm in town for the Draft.
- Oh awesome.
- For VeynerSports and stuff, I do that.
- Nice to meet you.
- Thank you for saying
hello, thank you, thank you.
- [Man] This might be
the best day of my life.
- Why?
- [Man] Just like, I didn't think
we would have anything today.
- Guys, the lesson we learned today
is that Bobby Babin thought
we would have nothing,
instead I do an interview,
it becomes that kind of interview
where it just pops, completely,
and now Babin has something.
- I'm a big fan, man.
I'm Jason, how are ya?
- Thank you bro.
Jason?
- yep.
- Yeah, nice to meet you, man.
- Can I get a selfie with you?
- Yeah, of course, of course.
- This is the weirdest shit,
what are you doin' here?
- NFL Draft.
- For four years.
- That's awesome.
- Thanks man. You mind takin' it?
Thanks, dude.
Props for everything.
- Thank you bro, I wish you well.
Mission accomplished.
- Yeah, dude.
- Thank you, brother.
Me at like midnight last night
in a business meeting I'm like
jesus I gotta leave the apartment at 4:00,
I'm not even home from this day.
You know what it is?
I keep it actually very basic,
to me it's very simple.
If your actions don't match your ambition,
you're leaving a vulnerability.
I'm more than capable
of working nine to five
if that's what I want,
and to me I just love it,
I love the action, I love the game.
- [Man] Has it always been like that
or was there a moment
where you were like damn,
this game's a shame I should
have switched and quit.
- There was one moment actually,
but it was actually
for the reverse reason.
At my 30th birthday I was
driving to the Wine Library,
my first business, and it's weird,
I can remember like yesterday,
I'm literally driving on the highway
and I had to look back
in the rear view mirror
to like, I don't know, I'm just driving.
I looked in my rear view mirror,
and for some reason I made
eye contact with myself,
and for the last 15 minutes of that drive
of an hour commute, I
basically told myself
I was full of shit, even
though I'd accomplished a lot.
I'm 30, I built this $50 million business,
but it wasn't mine, right,
I was doing it for my
family and I was like,
I kind of just said bro,
if you don't do something soon,
all that hyperbole of
like owning the Jets,
you're not, you're gonna
become an embarrassment
of, you know, and that's kind
of why I give the advice,
like, all these kids like,
I'm gonna be a billionaire,
I'm like not if you go to Coachella
and you know, not if you
don't put in the work.
You can go to Coachella,
not if you don't put in the work.
And you can go to
Coachella, Coachella just,
that's just a funny thing to reference.
It's not if you're not
putting in the work.
Not if you're working in a SoHo House,
for eight hours but you're really
working an hour, you know?
You're either working or you're not,
and so, and you gotta work smart.
I was working my fuckin' ass
off on that 30th birthday,
it was jut, I wasn't putting myself
in a position to succeed,
and so that became, that was the seed,
that was the one time where I was like,
I'm disappointing myself.
I've never been upset about working hard,
I've never felt burnt out in my life,
meaning, I get tired,
but you're only burnt
out if you don't love it.
I get burnt out of doing homework
for one hour in my
entire career of school,
so I'm an extremist that way, right?
The reason I was a D and F student
and the reason that I don't burn out now
is I'm either, it's binary.
I'm either in my zone or I'm not.
And when I'm in my zone it's a hundred,
and when I'm not it's zero.
I'm just not capable,
it's also why I think I've been able
to be popular in my humility,
I can't change, I'm me.
My ability to not be
me is like nonexistent.
I don't have it, you know,
I don't have it in me.
- Sorry.
- No worries.
- I will deal with the university.
- What's your name?
- That was worth leaving school.
- Cheers.
You're gonna be impressed.
Hold on, hold on.
All right I cheated, I cheated.
- I didn't think you cheated that bad.
- I didn't think so either.
God dammit.
- Gabriel.
- Gabriel, it's nice to meet you, man.
- You just inspire me, man.
- Thank you.
- I just wanna help people
who struggle with depression.
- I get it, me too.
- End depression,
- you know what?
We're not gonna end it,
we're just gonna have better conversations
around it so that people can,
you know what I mean?
- Eliminate the stigma.
- Exactly, that's all, that's all.
Nothing about ending,
it's about making it fucking coexist
with all the other fuckin'
shit in the world, you know?
That's what's up, man.
- So can I get a picture of you?
- Of course.
- Is that okay?
- Yeah, of course.
- I won't take much of your time.
- No worries.
Gettin' ready, big day. Put the
green suit on, you know why.
I'm very excited, so proud
of Josh and all of our guys,
so proud of AJ and Tommy
and Brian, the whole team.
Just a big day in the process.
I'm very excited about it,
really lookin' forward to it.
Be a lot of fun, big, big day,
do a little red carpet,
do a little green room,
do a little post game,
we'll see what happens.
We've got Josh Jackson,
we've got the New York Jets,
we've got some big moments.
And friends and family,
everybody watchin',
just a lot of fun stuff.
So super excited and most
of all on a day like this,
I'm most excited for Bobby Babin,
'cause he woke up this morning at 4 a.m.
thought he wasn't gonna get any content
and he got so much fire he doesn't know
what to do with himself.
Literally Babin I think got
at least six Instagram micro-clips
from that one interview.
I was in rare form.
Anyway, super excited about it, fired up,
let's see what happens tonight,
it's a special night, it's gonna be wild.
- Bobby Babin.
- Yeah.
- Admit it, you got way better
content than you expected.
- Way better, I was not happy
about the 4 a.m. wake up call,
that I didn't think I was gonna film.
- Did you underestimate me?
- A little bit.
- And what happened?
- It turns out you're
really famous in Dallas.
- Famous in Dallas.